I want to talk about something that's
really stunning and I don't think I've
interviewed anybody else that has this
honor
you have your own postage stamp is this
correct yes now I can't believe I mean I
don't know anybody who's on a postage
stamp actually a mom in the valley you
cannot believe I'm on a host yeah you're
a mom that lives in the valley well
you're also sama Blair but explain let's
show the postage stamp this is what
would yeah I mean this is ivory coast
yeah I mean it says 2009 but I'm
bringing it back
yeah I want to promote that okay but
how's my question what is your
connection to the Ivory Coast why are
you on their postage stamp they didn't
ask me I wouldn't have said no but I was
gonna go on a class trip their senior
year with Professor dead bogies class he
was from the Ivory Coast there's not a
reason my mom was worried I'd get sick I
didn't go but then I get the stamp that
is I got a letter in the mail and I'm on
a stamp no I didn't get a letter in the
mail with that as a stamp but someone
sent it to me okay no wait a minute
I just don't understand I someone help
me if anyone out there watching has the
answer to how you because you're very
beautiful woman you're famous but it's
there's a randomness to the Ivory Coast
puts you on a postage stamp without
asking you and then you're there that's
I didn't get a free trip no one's
invited me to the Ivory Coast again I
would like to go yeah I'm on their stamp
I'm practically like the president yeah
I'm an ambassador in a way yeah I would
love to find out how that and ER I don't
know they're just they're probably
Hellboy fans yeah
you